I got a question in the break that make
New Year's that there's one thing I
really did not make clear so let me just
reiterate one thing that I explained
badly in the first hour that I want to
make sure people understand so I said I
want to explain again how you go from to
approver or multi prover but letting of
to prove ur - delegation okay so
remember we had a we assumed we had a to
prove her scheme where each prover had a
query was quiet q1 and q2 and send back
an answer in the delegation scheme we
have only one prover and the verify what
he will do he will send each of these
queries encrypted okay so it's an
encryption nobody had an encryption of
q1 with one public key an encryption of
q2 with another fresh public key now
what does this prove urdu he doesn't see
these queries how does the answer so we
use fully homomorphic encryption which
means what what this proofer does he
gets this box with this query with query
1 he does not see query 1 but he applies
a function to query one to get answer 1
and what is this function exactly the
function that this p1 does okay so he
answers underneath the hood he gets this
box remember of shines gloves or jenna
Craig's gloves right there's q1 in there
he pretends the function that p1 does he
applies this function to q1 and get back
the encrypted answer a one where he
still does none has no idea what q1 is
or what I want is they're both encrypted
but he still managed to do the
computation underneath the hood using
fully homomorphic encryption ok and
again it when when this heuristic was
suggested they didn't have fully on
warfarin krypton they had Peter but I
don't want to go into into that so is
that clear more or less just to me ok ok
so thanks for for asking the question so
I got a chance to clarify ok so where
were we so we said if we only had n IP
multipolar interactive
ma P that is secured against no
signaling strategies we're done we
thought the problem delegation okay so
let me just recall and give you some
context of this notion of no signaling
so this notion was actually studied for
several decades now starting the mid-80s
and it's inspired by quantum physics so
let me explain you what this notion is
in the context of mostly proven
attractive proofs so we have a multiple
interactive proofs and classically sorry
classically we assume that these provers
do not interact at all they're in
separate rooms they cannot interact they
answer locally okay is that a reasonable
assumption I think so you put them in
the front they can interact however
quantum physicists may disagree because
they can say wow you know you can put in
different rooms for all I care you can
put them in different planets but what
if they share some quantum entangled
state then they can use this entangle
States to cheat the system ok and indeed
now we know we have a lot of time in
talked about it and we have a lot of
work or people really interested in
trying to base cryptography or more
generally complexity theory so on and
assuming that the scheme will remain
secure even against these adversary's
that use quantum entanglement or any
kind of physical means ok so we want to
say ideally we would want to say this in
fact this MIP is secure even if these
two pools that are sitting in different
room sharing a quantum entanglement ok
you can go a step further and say well
you know quantum theory is known to be
incomplete knows what else they can do
maybe there's some other physical means
that these two approvers can use to
cheat the and quantum entanglement so I
want to make sure that no matter what
they do they cannot cheat the only thing
I'm willing to assume in here is
Einstein here is that information the
not travel faster than the speed of
light so I know that they do not
interact with their ancestors that the
only thing I'm willing to assume in this
gave rise to the notion of no signalling
strategies so most of them strategies
just says that look I don't know what
they can do
think of these provers are being really
really far away so the very fact sitting
in the middle one two versus and Mars
one provers in Jupiter and he's sitting
in the middle and he's looked I don't
know they may even though they're far
away they may share quantum entanglement
and God knows what they can share but I
know that information cannot travel
between them so I the only thing I'm
willing to assume is that this answer
he's given q1 this answer does not
contain additional information you talk
with other wise how does this
information travel right so that the
answers are no signaling no signaling
says these what an awesome strategy is a
strategy that none is a fairly local so
the ends are no singing strategy a one
is not necessarily a function only of q1
it can be a function of both q1 and q2 a
randomized function and the only thing
my only restriction on this strategy and
the answer are the answer is that the
distribution of the answer does not
contain information about the other
query or in other words this answers a
random variable and the other query are
independent or saying it even maybe
saying it differently if I use this
board I'll say it in many ways because
there's it's a concept that's hard to
grasp so I'm just gonna say it in 100
different ways another way to say it is
so what's an or signaling strategy it's
a function it can be a randomized
function of both q1 and q2 randomized
function and it's no signaling if when
you look at this answer this is for work
you two and for another q2
it's exactly the same distribution so
the distribution of these answers are
the same so the distribution of a1 is
the same as the distribution of a1 prime
so don't look at the answer as a number
look at it as a distribution this
distribution is not affected by the
other query that's no signaling and more
generally yes so that's a very good
question
so no signaling they're exactly the same
in our paper it's not that's not enough
because I want to use signaling to break
that fake Chi so the encryption so to
enough to say you know security holds
only if they're completely completely
the same I need to leverage so I'm
actually using we're using the notion of
kind of Delta no signaling so our MIP
needs to be secure against more than
just no signaling it needs to be secure
even against tiny signaling actually you
can think about so we don't do
computational but you can think of
computational signaling and I can talk a
lot about that but but yeah in our work
we talk about statistical no signaling
okay and more generally here we talked
about two approvals but actually and are
actually proof we're gonna have many
provers like k provers okay security
parameter and the requirement is that
take a bunch of queries you know queuing
up to queue a sidenote to the first s
provers and look at their answers the
distribution of their answers it's the
same no matter what other queries are at
the distribution okay so when you look
at the distribution you can you look at
the answers the random variable that
correspond to the answers it doesn't
give you information about the other
queries why is it enough for you because
you want to break fhe design this to
that this is the connect formation
terrific thing this MIT
signal approval cheating provers kind of
I mean in this world this one cheating
Kluber he can do something where you
know it's only competition I mean he so
so if genious question is why didn't
have to have statistical no signaling so
the answer is computational no singling
would have been better it would give you
l w e polynomial lwe with statistical no
signaling I just know that an
all-powerful person can without the
queue so I'll put an all-powerful person
if you have a statistical no signaling
it just means that a 1r distinguishment
by all-powerful people but these a ones
are very short think of it as poly log
so all-powerful is quasi poly good so
now the question is do we have these MIP
that secure against these no signaling
strategies okay and again just as a
sanity check note classical on my Peas
are the most goes here we're really the
cheap so we had ma P to have fun
tomorrow if he's no singling in ma peace
in all of these I'm thinking the honest
provers are local okay so there's no
point to nothing in honest provers now
the question is what's the power of the
adversary here we're really tying his
hands he's local he only answers you
know he sees his query and answers and
here we have the by fault no moot result
that says you can do all of next now
with what am I'm giving the adverse very
more power and telling him look you can
do angle you can have in quantum
entanglement now let's see so now you
know it's harder they that recipes have
more power so it's harder to get
security and this was an open problem
what what's the power of this quantum
MIT class and there's been a
breakthrough work and breakthrough work
in the quantum literature quantum
complexity literature in 2012 that shows
that again the power of this quantum I
my piece is exactly next okay now no
signaling we're getting there are even
more power we tell me you know what use
whatever you want as long as
you know you don't transfer information
okay so you can use any physical mean
that I don't know what exists out there
you can use it as long as you don't
break as long as you can talk to your
ancestor I'm willing Testim that you can
do anything everything else so now what
can we do and here is what's known the
frustrating thing is you can't do more
than X that's not the slightly good news
you can do pspace at least but even here
is what's frustrating because the
running of the prover like in that IP
equals p space it's again due to that
squared so for delegation we can't use
it
okay the horrible each one exponential
time it does fall for my pupils P space
but you need to I mean you need to see
that IP corresponds to oh okay sorry now
I understand what you're saying so that
ma p is not interactive it's query
answer okay but IP can be converting to
no signalling ma P so it does actually
follow but it's this is not an
interactive setting so it doesn't follow
trivially okay so this is what's known
and what we show is because if we
classify we say it's exactly expect okay
so we can't all the terms the clarify
exactly which all we show that every
determine deterministic computation
t-time computation we show we construct
a null signaling proof
we're with you the proof of runtime is T
squared o tilde of T squared the bear
fires on time is quasi linear and the
communication depends only in the
security parameter and now I want to
show you this the MIP and again I want
to focus tress before I mean nothing's
great i I'm interested in it very much
but I'm not interested because I'm
worried about quantum entanglement
I wanted the cryptography I want to do
the delegation and the reason I'm
obsessed and I really want to solve this
problem is because it gives me
delegation so now oh yes coffee
you know the promise phenomena may
propose the runtime of the verifier it
depends on the number of provers so
that's where you pay but the provers
runtime does not depend on the number of
provers game okay so way any more
questions now so next time we're going
to do the construction I'm going to show
you how to construct this it might be
okay hey okay but first I just yes wow
that's scary
hey I don't know I'm not I don't know
much about quantum but you know one
thing I like but one thing I really like
about the no singling by the way is
exactly these things so you know you
want to prove something as resilient to
quantum attacks I don't know about you
guys but as soon as I see the CAD
notation that gets you know stressed out
so the quantum they there are no
signaling it's very nice it's it's it's
probability distributions so we can
actually work on it you know we can
actually do things without you know
getting this all these cats around us a
so so you can think of it as an
abstraction actually a nice mathematical
so for those who feel comfortable in
math world and feel uncomfortable in the
physics world it's you know I see
okay so just again I want to do the MIP
why do I want to do that my pee because
if I have no signal on my pee then I
didn't done I just I get my my two
message delegation scheme okay and this
to message delegation scheme is secure
assuming the cloud cannot solve all the
blue cannot break the encryption okay
so construction okay so before so okay
now at this point I first from now on I
stole ones slides so thank you um
so from now on things are going to
improve okay
the slides okay so the sides are going
to be nicer but I won't be able to give
you all the details because just to
explain what really a PCP is or MIP is
it requires kind of course more or less
I will take me you know kind of a
semester no I'm glad rating but it takes
a lot of time so I'm gonna use a lot of
things as black boxes and not explained
but at least I'm gonna try to tell you
where you'll know at least what I'm not
explaining and what I am explaining okay
so I'm going to construct this no single
area maybe that's secured against my
nose signaling strategies so let's start
with construction okay so what are the
provers do okay I have a bunch of
provers I'm gonna have actually many
provers like security parameter number
of provers what do they do they get an
input F and X what do they do
so first thing they do they generally
gotta block the computation so think of
f as a Turing machine you generate the
entire tableau okay so the height is at
the time which is the space here we have
the input bits the output bit is sitting
over here they generate this tableau
first thing second thing they encode
this tableau they encoded using a PCP a
politically check about proof I'm not
gonna explain exactly how this PCP works
just think of it you take the tableau
and you encode it in a way using a PCP
what are this PCP are for you it offers
you this is I'm just using PCP the black
box now it offers your way to read only
a few random location for the verifier
to read only a few random location and
big convinced that this entire tableau
is correct with high probability okay so
you can verify the correctness of all of
this using a few locations that's what
what this PCP does okay so they encode
it we use the bye-bye fault no a loon
living [ __ ] PCP but probably any
other PCP would look this is kind of one
of the you know classical PCBs we don't
I don't think we need anything specific
from this PCP so you can for now think
of it as a general PCP so you can call
your computation using a PCP and you
expect to be asked one one point so you
generate this PCP you expect to be
answered one query in this PCP one
location you can track the number of
that sitting there the bit that's
sitting there that's it
hey that's what the prover does so
remember before I told you that MIP
and PCP are essentially the same this is
that maybe it's just a PCP each one
calls the computations in repeats it
expects to get an a question ask one
location of this PCP okay and again I
did not tell you what this PCP does how
exactly encodes it and you don't need to
know for this to understand this result
oh how about the verifier the very
potent is the PCP verifier so he just he
there's the BFL s-wave a PCP the
verifiers there what it does he
generates a few queries and think about
security parameter number of queries and
he'll send one query to each prover in a
random order okay so give each prover a
query get back the answers and except if
the PCP verify accept so he's just
pretending you know that he had that
he's a PCP verify one kind of technical
point but it's kind of interesting is
that we don't really use the PCP Aziz
but rather in the PCP there the verifier
does many kind of consistency checks or
many tests we repeat each one k times
okay so we does we do some amplification
and this implication is important for us
it's some sound simplification and one
of the reasons why this an amplification
is very important for us is because with
no signal link for general no signaling
we do not have parallel repetition so
this is a way of getting around this
problem that we don't have parallel
petition we amplify sounds by
repeating the tests but for those who
didn't understand it forget it it's not
important no we don't know how to prove
Pirela it's an open forum we know how to
prove it for to prove errs maybe some
extensions a few but we don't know
general parallel petition results for no
signalling for no signalling for
classical we have analyzed the petition
so that's what we do so essentially we
do a PCP you know we take the two-way
the poopers it won't cut PCP where's
queries get answers we amplify by doing
this thing in parallel that's it okay
what's the analysis so let's first let
me first tell you how the classical
analysis work
forget about no signalling how do we
prove that that this thing is
classically sound against the classical
attacks the classical adversary's that
just see their own query so the way it
works is the phone you say well if the
cheating provers convinced the verifier
to accept namely they passed the kind of
random consistency checks that the
verifier did remember that a pcp the
verifier just kind of ran a where it's
from a few random location in dozen
tests so if these random consistency
checks passed
okay the verify accepted it means them
that the pcp must be that blow delivered
at the blow must be consistent
everywhere with high probability and
then they go from lowball consistency to
global consistency and hence correctness
this point this should be totally buggy
or weird or doesn't make any sense to
most of you why what do you mean local
consistency everywhere so these provers
they generated these provers generated
it to blow so they generate the sublime
just gonna put in a long string doesn't
matter I'm asking a few location and
accept a consistency everywhere how do I
know that you know here I have
consistency I never asked these places
so how can I expect that everywhere I'll
have consistently makes no sense
so let me explain to you what I mean
that you get local consistency
everywhere so you never when you wanna
query a point in the PCP
you never query that specific point
rather you do a decoding okay so you
think of the PC pitch and encoding of
the entire to blow and you want to know
what's written in a specific place on
the tableau your decode you don't need a
specific point because again you know if
this isn't one can put them whatever you
want whatever you want you'll never read
it anyway so you can that that won't
you'll never get down this this way so
how do we quote unquote read a point the
way most PC P's work the way you read a
point so this encoding is essentially
reed-muller encoding for those who've
you know a little bit about coding
theory in the way so it's some
polynomial encoding it's and the way you
read a point you take a random line
through this point and you interpolate
that's how you most PC peas work if you
don't understand doesn't matter think of
it as some decoding okay in our work
like I said we amplify soundness
by repeating each test many times the
way we would read a point is we take K K
security parameter K random lines
through this point we'll and we'll take
the majority so interpolate and take the
majority that's how we read a point but
what I want to stress is the way I read
a point is by asking a bunch of queries
where each query on its own is
completely random okay so in even if the
point is stuck here in the end and then
I read it by asking random queries okay
and that's why I can get local
consistency everywhere and now also this
high probability makes sense the
hyperbole is over the verifiers lines or
the verifiers decoding how does it
decode the local decoding the randomness
used for local decoding okay so
classical mouse is that how data works
you go from random from random kind of
that the random consistency checks are
good to the fact that you have local
consistency everywhere okay and then
they go from this is usually done in the
PC case
where you have some stronger soundness
but the point is that the no signaling
is enough to guarantee because one
prover doesn't know what you know the
distribution of the answer can't because
to all the provers together right so
here actually when I'm explaining this
I'm explaining it's more in the pcp
setting of the post of the MIP setting
but it's really the thing and actually
then alphas in our paper we use the PCP
we use the cons we use the terminology
of no signaling PCP as opposed to MIP
you can say it's a very interchangeable
it's really one in the same
you know PCP MIP it's it's the same
creature so it's whatever more
comfortable the distinction PCP versus
MIT with the distinction of the static
object versus the no signaling no
signaling is enough to make this PCP to
classical PCP technique work okay good
so yes so that's how the classical
setting works in the PCP
now with the no signaling now I that's
the way I said but not before is what
how classical PCP works that's the proof
okay the proof that's that kind of
highlight the two main kind of part what
about the no signaling now our
adversary' is no signaling he has more
power okay he doesn't have to be
classical so how do we prove security
against this guy so again it's the same
idea
first we told that if he manages to
convince the verify to accept the random
consistency checks then he must be
locally consistent everywhere with high
probability and this part really using
just the same PCP techniques so again I
don't explain to these techniques
because it requires a lot of in from
just takes too long but the same
techniques it just works
you need to work hard and it works and
our amplification lemma because we don't
have parallel repetition but let me I
want to just maybe explain this again in
some other words so remember we have the
tableau what do I mean by local
consistency you think of the tableau as
you know a circuit right with we all a
layered circuit and there's kind of
gates here and and by local that didn't
say I mean that if here was the 1 and
here 0 here also has to be a 1 it's
hopefully consistent
and when I read the value here in here
and here I read it by decoding what's
funny yes
okay I need them plication I need so
that's the next why do I need very good
soundness so what yeah that's the next
very nice union-bound see someone's
listening I didn't get there yet
someone's just smart enough to jump
outta me okay
so why do I need so I want here to get
local consistency with very high
probability so I want to be everyone
that tableau is correct with very high
probability how high 1 minus epsilon
would think of that sounds very small
smaller than 1 over T squared okay think
of it's very small why do I want this to
go from local to global okay so in the
classical setting how do they logo from
local consistency to global consistency
let me first show how are you they doing
the classical setting in the classical
setting it's super easy that's the
easiest part of the PCP let me show it
to you in one slide okay how do you do
it well okay you want to prove that your
globally consistent publican sentiments
everything is correct and everything is
consistent what's the probability that
your globally consistent well it's 1
minus the probability that you're not ok
that somewhere there's a local
inconsistency okay so then think about
the blow you can think I never each gate
gate gate if everything is locally
consistent the inputs are consistent
with the XOR of text then everything is
local consistent then then everything is
correct okay so the probability that
your locally consistent I mean that your
locally consistently everywhere sorry
which is one minus the probability that
somewhere you're inconsistent what's the
probability that somewhere you're
inconsistent well Union bound how many
gates are there we have it to blow up
three times this so mine is TS times
this epsilon now if I think that's so
small enough that's why I need the
amplification if that's something small
enough smaller than you know I take one
over T to the third then you're very
close to one and I'm done okay that's
the classical so the classical all the
work was in the first part this part
that's all local to global trivial
now no signaling what's going on with
the no signaling this completely fails
and why does it fail this doesn't make
any sense
what does it mean to be local
consistency everywhere now the adversary
his answers depend on all the and the
queries so you give him some queries
because you wanted to give him other
queries you give him another answer
there is no everywhere let me maybe
explain this go back actually to our
example of coloring okay so take our
locally consistent adversary who
convinces us that our non colorable
graph is 3 colorable okay oh geez here
locally consistency everywhere if you
look at each two you ask him
give me two two verdun if cheers to
vertices black and red good two vertices
green and red so but how could you don't
global consistency from that so maybe
let me explain it
again city setting right what's written
it one entry of the table is what's
written one if I ask this and that or
this and that exactly exactly exactly in
the stand the classical PCP when i
reaiiy can read a point on the tableau
now when i know it's very hyperbole
eight seven eight seven
now every the next one with very
hyperbole time it's nine that's it
in the know something this is not the
case in the no signaling if you think
about our 3 colorable graph well you
have some graph you ask these two red
and blue you ask these two green and
blue you how did that the mobile
consistency from the local okay now the
answers actually function as irrelevant
as though it's independent but it has a
function it's a function of the other
queries and that's where this fails so
for us this is the part that's actually
going from local consistencies the
global consistency that's the part that
require new ideas that's what I need to
depart from the classical PCP can you
think about completely differently and
need to go from local to global using
other techniques I don't think so
because well yeah if you if you had to
okay to violate global consistency you
had to violate local consistency then
the answer is yes but often even if you
resilient to noise even if there's noise
a it it doesn't it still doesn't mean
the local consistency plant global
consistency so if you had a circuit
where local implies global then the
answer is yes but it was
it's not you so I don't think that
redundancy will help you here
if you think of 3 colorable okay let's
take it offline I'm not sure but I don't
think redundancy will help you but let
me think about it more later here you'll
see ok ok getting local consistency you
can get 4 next ok so I can find I can
come up with even if their languages was
non-deterministic I can still prove that
if you succeeded in cheating me you have
to be locally consistent but I can't
prove that you're globally consistent
that you're correct and here you'll see
exactly why so what I have I'm showing
that kind of the standard MIP with some
simplification it's a it for
non-deterministic languages if if the
adversary's local he cannot cheat for
deterministic languages sorry for
deterministic languages even if he's no
signaling cannot read but I can't prove
that if for non-domestic languages if
you're no singling then you actually can
cheat there's an attack because you're
neck specific you'll see now now you'll
see it's the part that I go from local
consistency to global consistency so now
I have that my P and suppose for I'm
gonna suppose that I have my adversary
that he manages to convince me of local
consistency that you know he does he
cheats but in a way then when I asked
these three he's locally consistent when
asked these three is awfully consistent
when athletes you know this cake is not
very consistent
I want to prove to you that it means
that he's globally consistent that this
is correct and I'm gonna really use in a
very strong way the fact that this
language is determined that this
computations determine
and you'll see why right now okay yes
right in the classical setting not in my
setting in my settings on Union bound
because that's what stuff no way of
checking this so she tell you in the
graph she's locally consisted everywhere
I think and let's think again let's
think again think again of the 3
colorable graph example ok
I can I can move these that the graph is
3 colorable even if it's not I can prove
2 with probability 1 that it's recolor
go and it always also consistent for any
tool you look at consistent it doesn't
imply global consistency so if I just
repeat the same query many times you
repeat it ok
if you okay good look good
so why good that's what you're asking
you're asking well the more questions
you'll ask the more your locality will
grow and it will help you but you look
if you're asked the entire graph then
yes if he's consistent in the entire
graph you know you got a 3 coloring so
you can ask give me all the colors but
they did you want short you you don't
wanna you want the proof to be insurance
you don't want the proof to be give me
all the colors so how local you are so I
think local consensus you can what do
you mean by local local meaning I know
you know is this local is this how local
is local you know so I'm gonna we're
gonna see that right now okay but the
more the bigger the locality is the
easier our proof will become and I'm
gonna really use it right now so maybe
I'll jump into the proof and you'll see
ok so here's the first attempt to go
from local to global ok let's look at
these I know that it's local consistency
what are the mean that a local
consistency
well this is consistent with the input
so this is x1 x2 and this is consistent
with these which means it's correct the
correct value okay so I know that by
local consistency what I have here is
correct good I know signaling it means
that what I have here is correct even if
I ask other queries because whether it's
correct or not doesn't matter on the
other queries it's no signalling and
here already I'm using the fact that it
is deterministic already here what I
mean correct think of the three coloring
the example case what colors it's red is
that correct or not there's no there's
not just no such thing as correct color
is it you and here I'm really using the
fact is what's written here is it
correct is it really x1 and x2 or not
okay by no signalling it's still correct
good also this should be courts
probability 1 minus epsilon same
argument exactly's before now let's go
here I get local consistency with
probability 1 minus epsilon now if this
was correct this was correct and this is
consistent then this is also correct so
I get that this one is quite this
probably 1 minus 3 epsilon okay okay
it's still correct even if I didn't ask
these queries as other queries because
it's no signaling it's on and so forth
in the ice layer I said the same thing I
say well this is if this is quote was
from furball t1 - I know some epsilon I
and it is correct with property 1 minus
epsilon I this is consistent so it's
also quotes local t1 minus 2 epsilon
minus epsilon so and then I'll get
correctness well it's fine but the
arrows grows exponentially
ok so I think if this was correct and
this was correct and I'm consistent then
I made progress but I need both to be
correct and so I lose I add my air
doubles each layer so it only gives me
delegation for low depth computation
that's not good enough for me I mean
that's fine we had we knew how to do
that before with the depth of D but I
want to go beyond that
and again I want to note that we did use
the determinism to make progress because
we always had them you know there was
some anchor in this correct or not we
don't have this anchor in
non-deterministic computations but if
there was if you knew there was a no it
wouldn't because uh a unfortunately okay
so that's not good enough because they
are doubled let me show you how the how
to get rid of their doubling and yeah
I'm gonna go to what you suggested which
is let's make my locality bigger suppose
I had enough provers to actually ask
them give me the values of all these
gates okay so suppose I had like more
than s the space number of provers and I
ask all of them queries and I could
interpolate and find all these values so
I have a lot of provers like the space
which corresponds to the verifier
running in a lot of time like the space
yeah we're actually we're using that
we actually we can make it redundant by
but we still so maybe I'll get to that
in a minute
but we actually we use this technique
inside I'm okay so if if you asked if
you could ask all these queries to the
provers then now all this is local
consistent okay so we can if they're if
they're locally consistent then what
does it mean to all this to be local
consistent this is the input and this is
consistent with it which means it's
correct
so get correctness probably one minus
Epsilon for the whole layer for the
whole two layers let's say no if this
layer is correct with up to one minus
epsilon it's still correct even if it's
asked with the next layer because it's
no signaling whether it's correct or not
does not depend on other queries so
you're still this is still correct and
with probably 107 epsilon this is
consistent now this is correct and this
is consistent then this is correct so
you've got correctness you paid another
epsilon okay and if this is correct it's
still correct if you ask the next layer
because it's no signaling this is
correct does not affect whether the
other queries are here or here otherwise
it signal with what other queries are
and so on and so forth so again you get
that this is code for building 1 minus 2
Epsilon what about this it's consistent
ability 1 minus epsilon so it's correct
or ability 1 - ok and so on and so forth
you go up up up up up you've got the top
layers questions about Bill T 1 minus T
Epsilon
and so now as long as epsilon is smaller
than 1 over T squared we're good this
actually works ok so we avoid the
doubling of there the exponential loss
in the air unfortunately we paid in the
run time of the verify or the number of
provers now the verifier the number of
provers is like the space the bear fires
runtime is like the space and we got the
legation for small space computation and
that was actually our first result was
for only linear space computations
third attempt which I'm not gonna talk
about at all but I just want to mention
is how to improve the locality so I
showed you if you had the locality there
like the space we are good we don't want
us from that and this goes back maybe to
Benny's point so how do you improve
locality I'm not going to say anything
about it because it's but just in one
sentence the idea is that before you do
the PCP encoding when you have the
tableau encode each layer of the tableau
so take the layer apply an aircraft
encode to it take the second layer apply
an error-correcting code and so on and
so forth and then apply PCP on this
tableau and then code it to blue
why what does it help us the only thing
I want to say why it helps us is it's
more redundant and and the way
essentially what we're using here we
think you don't need to check the entire
layer to be sure that the layer is
correct it's enough to check a random
point in the load of extension if
there's some wear error in the layer the
error will propagate and there being a
lot of errors in the extension to you'll
catch it by just reading one point
instead of the entire layer I know this
is very little information but just to
give a sense of the things we're dealing
with
yeah yeah so no it's a good point
so would be not as asking you already
have a PCP why didn't even code indent
or PCP maybe you don't but we wanted to
this is a black box it's very simple to
do it this way but maybe you can use
you're asking why do ten code again you
have already in encoding maybe you can
use out or encoding in that button maybe
but just makes this makes everything
more modular and cleaner okay so this is
okay that's all I want to say about the
the proof but what I want to convince
you is we essentially used a standard we
started with kind of an arbitrary PCP
probably a lot of other ones will exist
it's kind of the standard PCP that's
used for for classical in the classical
setting and we put for that for
deterministic languages it's even
secured against no signaling adversary's
okay so against the stronger adversary'
that's not necessarily local but if the
going okay and the pores runtime that
was squared because he run in the
tableau that the block can be kind of T
times s in the worst case s the spaces
like the time so that's why the T
squared here the verify turns out to be
very efficient in the PCP that just out
how it works
the communication is very small these
are things that we get from the PCP yeah
it failed yeah I'll tell you why it
fails how do you know that what you have
there in what I'm saying I'm saying I
made a progress so the cheat improver
now I have a cheating over there is no
witness okay
he's cheating I'm thinking X that's not
in the language so let me just repeat
the question I felt was asking again the
question that I got to be not adjusted
before I got you asked it sorry right
why
what if you have only unique witness why
doesn't this work so I'll tell you let's
try to see the proof and you'll see what
why it fails now I have a cheating prove
er X is not in the language we don't
have a witness not one and not more than
one zero down the language okay we don't
have any witness and now you're trying
to prove okay look he's not writing the
witness any words witness is big so you
look at the one bit of the witness once
the witnesses once you get a red one
together yellow you read it with this
way you got red you agree with that
yellow there's still emotion of
correctness you see I mean there is no
witness so every time you can lie each
time you give you a small witness you
know like a small part and then this
party can lie so it's confusing cuz it
seems like what there is a witness
there's a notion of correctness but when
he's lying there is no witness there's
nothing there so that's why it doesn't
work
yes basic started used to split this
so no signalling contains no ceiling is
more general than classic so no
signalling I'm saying look he can give
me an arm he can be classical so just
the function cannot be only a function
of q1 the reductions and the reduction
from MA pizza here or what sorry can you
repeat the ok ok no no so I guess good
so I want say either he's classical it's
all right I don't he's no signalling in
the reduction I didn't say it's
classical no sing Lang said either he's
no signaling or he's signalling no
signaling includes classical so in there
in the reduction so yeah I think the
reduction from MIP to delegation yeah
right let me pay the delegation so
there's out the reduction from MEP the
delegation says look there's the
adversary' either he's using a no
signaling strategy which includes
classical classical is also no signaling
its classical czar very benign no
signaling strategy you don't think all
the few classical so either use that
type of of of a tear of a dresser II and
then you break my no signaling scheme
because my scheme it's the cue against
no signaling strategies or or are they
aware does come or use a signaling
strategy but if you think now then I
can't this is not good so I think of him
ahead of time he applies some function
to the queries this function that he
applies is either either a one signals
information about q2 or it doesn't if it
doesn't it may be in maybe classical it
may be you know like it's just local it
doesn't say confirmation then I break
the know signaling MIP if it signals
information I'm gonna break my fhe
because I got information yes
in just a little bit I mean why is your
good so the answer is you're right I
cheated what I actually proved I proved
that I am a peer secure against
strategies that signal a little bit and
now if you signal me a little bit you
break them IP if you say no more than a
little bit then you break their finchy
so my are actually our actual theorem is
that it's secure even if you signal tiny
bit
you're still secure and if your signal
more than that tiny bit then you break
the FEG okay so in the last ten minutes
can I say something about memory
delegation okay
so that was very nice but as I said my
original so for those who lost me you
can join welcome okay so let's go to
original problem
okay as memory delegation so now we have
our user X is not small anymore X is
actually huge just an entire memory he
puts the entire memory in the sky he
keeps a short commitment to the memory
and I know he asks the cloud to do
computations for him okay and he gets
back the answer of the computation was
the proof in is a and more generally
this computation can actually change the
memory and if it changes the memory then
he expects a new commitment to his
memory because the memory is now changed
and we want to make sure that this proof
is its sound and that it has our
efficiency guarantees that we weren't
what we get is actually as we talked
about the verify runtime only dependent
Security's parameter independent the
memory or of the runtime of the
computation and there's very little
overhead in the provers runtime so he's
like we think of f as a ram program and
again in this setting Ram is very
important because the memory is huge I
think you can think of it as like
exponential you know so there's a big
gap possibly between Turing machine and
RAM in this setting okay so Bluebird
takes time proportional to the time of
the RAM computation
- put your initial day together Selenia
I mean there is no you just just give
the data you don't owe your staff
commitment yeah so yeah so let me tell
you actually okay I'll tell you in a
minute let me first
yeah so this is what I said this is the
theorem let me first mention the
previous work on this regime so and this
kind of memory delegation or sublinear
delegation so there have been works
there's been work on memory delegation
which is very similar it solves a
similar problem but they're the provers
runtime or the the clouds runtime always
the parody always needs to read the
entire database so even if you ask them
a tiny part of the database you need to
read the entire database so that was
kind of what we're trying to improve in
this work and then there was a lot of
related related models which all talked
about about interactive proofs of
proximity arguments of proximity
homomorphic signatures that we heard
about yesterday or the day before the
day before probably and and then there
would be also there were a lot of works
and and sublinear delegation for
specific functions okay which I'm not
gonna mention so okay so how do we go
how would we delegate round computation
the paradigm is very similar okay we say
well how about we do a multi prove a
proof for M computation and and then
we'll convert it to two are two massive
delegations came exactly as before so
that's that's the idea okay we'll do
multi prove or proof and convert it so
we learned something already that that
doesn't work only no signaling so our
focus this part to go for multi poverty'
won't proven exactly the same nothing
changes just use fhe the focus is how do
we get multi prove or oops for M and
note here before what was nice about the
work that exam before we very quickly
stripped away the crypto and we remained
an information theory land that's very
nice you know you don't need to run
after simulators and stuff in
assumptions and so on you and given
information theory land it's very nice
here unfortunately we don't have this
love
because this is that is not really a
proof it's still an argument why did an
argument because I delegate my huge
memory
I kept some small cache of this memory
and if the adverse we can find
collisions for this hash he can cheat me
so even though I went to the multiplayer
setting I didn't get my information
theory that we wanted but you know we
got at least we have many provers okay
so so we we do multi prove our argument
system not actually a proof system so
this is a computationally sound proof so
an all trading prove work at cheetahs
but we show that a computer as a cloud
that cannot break our hash function
cannot find collisions cannot cheat okay
so how does it work how does our multi
prove our interactive proof looks like
so first I'm going back to Afghanistan I
just give my data think about you know
there are many provers I give each one
my data and I keep a commitment what's
this commitment very simple just more
country okay so I just essentially any
commitment that's locally decodable will
work ok so what's a vertical tree again
any command that's locally decodable
will work well you can think I take my
memory and I hash down to K bits the K
bits and I go up up up and I I keep my
root the roots is my commitment okay how
does that so how does the no signaling
argument works I it's exactly the same
everything is exactly the same okay you
generated the Bravo computation you
encode that's a blow using a PCP and you
expect a big word in single query and
single point in you answer nothing
changed so what are the computation now
before we know what the computation was
it was just the tip of the computation
here we have a ram in the computation
includes need it also includes right but
let's forget about the right now just
for simplicity so all the sudden says
read this location what do we put in the
table so we put in the tableau we put
the value that we read along with that
deck amendment information which is kind
of a proof that what we read is indeed
what's in there what did the commitment
in our case it's just an augmented path
in the merkel hash
so now that the blue is just you know an
and gate and or gate it that it up read
what do you put in read you put the
value with augmented path and another or
another Anna Reeve you put the value in
an augmented path that's all you have
you do PCP here's something interesting
this computation is not deterministic
because there are this reads so you know
signaling we have only for deterministic
so it seems like paradoxical here how
does that work
I mean look that you so I mean usually
what before the computation one there's
the opponent there's and or and or not
here on some there's a read he puts me
whatever he wants in there so there's
kind of the read is kind of a
non-deterministic thing that the
adversary' you know the cheating provers
can put them whatever they want there's
some place of kind of non determinism
okay because then the read they actually
put kind of a witness in some sense the
value that so that seems like this may
approach may fail but here's what saves
us it's true that kind of mythic but for
polynomial time people it's
deterministic so either you find the
collision and then it's really not
deterministic and so on but then
everything breaks but if you can't find
collisions you have to put the correct
value in there you don't have room for
to play around so practically speaking
it is deterministic that's kind of the
high level idea yes the the client so
the client know so in the client he
first gives here's all my memory and
hash function that's that kind of
pre-processing if you want and then you
but if by the way you can think also
that there's no initial memory and you
just play over and over again in with
time kind of the memory arrives in which
case the first time you just give a hash
function any time you can give the
Fresno at the moment you start the game
you give them a hash function with the
first message it doesn't need to be kind
of ahead of time there's no adaptivity
issues or anything so that's that's
essentially the proof goes exactly the
same
to go to local consistence exactly is
before and local to global oh yes the
right thing that's supposed to be and
you so can you do it based on now second
very much religious so okay so again the
first question was yes ah the second
preimage can we do it based on second
preimage right if you want on adapter
publius yes right yeah so if you want to
verify the client to choose the function
ahead of time then you can do it based
on second preimage resistance but if you
want an adaptive solution where the
server potentially can affect the
function no okay good so one ask the
question what so the proof is very very
similar said that you know anyway it's
very similar you couldn't argue
everything but now you get correctness
unless the hash is broken unless the
house is broken but otherwise the proof
is the same and what the one asked you
still have the tip I promised time Oh
tilde of T but that the blood still T
squared and the answer is if you have a
hum then if you if you have this big
memory then you can make the table you
can use the space in the realm you can
make the table the space and there I am
always very small and store things
before you have to store everything in
your true machine now it starts thinking
the most time and RAM can become very
very short but maybe actually to giving
you a question after chi minh's talk we
talked about parallel Ram when you our
idea was just you can assume what the
RAM programs that the memory is always
this the tableau is very skinny but the
price you pay for having a skinny
tableau is you ruin your parallelism and
if you want to do payroll RAM we can't
you know then this becomes fat and if
this becomes fat then we need to go to
the third to here kind of in the carer I
showed you
the way to get around the space issue is
to use this aircraft in code and so on
here we don't use it because this is so
short anyway we don't even need to I
mean it's okay to have this many provers
this is only security parameter because
we can always assume that the RAM
program uses very little tableau memory
but if you want parallelism we can't so
that's kind of an interesting okay let
me summarize this is the theorem okay
this is my concluding slide so you know
we came across this connection to
delegation like two years ago I think it
has so many applications to cryptography
we're starting to get some applications
not even the surgical photography so I
have a recent work with Han where we
show connection to hardness of
approximating linear programming and I I
just think that has a lot of application
it's a very simple notion and so I
encourage all of you to join our forces
and work on it I really think there's a
lot of things to discover using this
notion sorry the only place I used out W
is Fe Chi I never used lwe I just and
peer actually actually from peer even
yeah yeah yeah yeah I didn't use that
face I didn't use lwe you know the
reason I vote a little use because I
don't really need them a usually once
fhe assume you need circle of security
and I don't need the circular security
so I wanted to you know to but yeah any
like we can do under many standard
assumptions essentially it's not just
hard approximation linear programming
yeah so a what we show is we show how
any if you have no signaling MIP we
convert it to a linear program that's
actually how the I told you that it's an
X that no singling MIP the next and a
the reason it's an X is can you can you
one can show it was shown that you can
convert it into a linear program and so
what we do essentially this is very very
high-level we take our instance any
instance in X and we reduce it into
linear program and so now if you can do
like better space complexity or
something to this linear program then
you have better space complexity for all
of X which is unlikely so it's just it's
just it's just boiled down to
transforming any no singling MIP fool in
your program that's essentially the the
one sentence
answer yes so okay so we have a
rejection problem but it's our problem
because we don't have we we don't reuse
it we think of it as two message
allegation and it doesn't mean each time
do fresh query if we read we could have
reused the query we could have made it
one round and have to use the same words
all the time and then we had a rejection
problem so one thing you can do is I
said it's to message put one message out
of time reuse it until you know
something that happens and then you can
do it ahead of time but it's not really
a problem because we're not relying on
some pre-processing previously mentioned
the work go for some caviar this long no
it's an improvement but different
assumption they use multi linear maps so
they improve in the fact that it's
publicly verifiable but the assumptions
are less studied you know you should see
similar efficiency similar efficiency
and for a homework from at Alinea
Marilyn ohm you'll find Marcus
assumptions polynomial so if you want to
do remember is that your so on can you
so there's there's other results which I
mentioned in the beginning that does
delegation for RAM for i/o but it's at
the security if I understand correctly
so excuse me if I don't answer correctly
the literature I am not I don't think I
understand it perfectly but if I
understand it correctly they get RAM
from i/o but the security only holds if
the adverse we cannot choose the
functions adaptively so in our case you
know so you give you give the RAM and
now there you want to say that no matter
what func what function is going to be
computed he can't cheat
well I mean yes or no I mean you know I
don't think you can because if you the
number of functions is unbounded but you
do it again and again and again and
again again unbounded many it I mean if
you do it one time yes but it's
interesting because it's huge memory you
the point is to do many computations and
it's unbounded so it's not clear to me
how to do leveraging she'll ensure this
is like done ok bubble do it publicly
verifiable the planet autumn but even
though I probably you can extend to Ram
as well and I believe so I would say the
main challenge publicly verifiable under
standard assumption or try to go to NP
non deterministic under standard
assumption I know Daniel and Craig may
object but still there's room for for
work on non-deterministic delegation
that kind of you know goes around Daniel
and Craig's negative result something
openers the distal setting is there
anything interesting for people who
don't do the computational stuff oh yeah
so we okay the most important right of
the obsession of guy in mandy
interactive proof with efficient provers
you know IP equals p space with
efficient provers that's the most
interesting question my opinion just
it's a complexity theory but yeah oh no
but I will poly number I Paloma many
messages yeah for two messages you can
do and because you don't think that a.m.
equals P space but Paloma the mini
rounds p space Hoover running time
polity therefore running time Paul yes I
see no anything for you at this point we
know to today's employers don't do this
actually the muggles give to to this but
none not better I want it
the irrigation for you well I guess this
rounds anyway I guess yeah you can do a
em is just too round yeah that's a
question did you have a question you're
asking can you do it so you askin can
you do like a second preimage or
something does anybody know can you do
for message under one way function I
would ask you you're the one I would ask
actually but the question can do it with
less than collision-resistant one we
functions so perhaps you should take
further